I'm trying to find my way in the world
you know trying to be somebody instead
of just make money off everybody if
there's something my mind speaking I
think being humble sexy I know you rich
I know you got 40 billion dollars but
can you just keep it to one house and
that's our job it's the spark I just
quit my job today actually because I
wanted to come and do this I think
everybody shines and different things we
argue please let us in we are pleased
that I said but I love my childhood even
though it was bad I love it you I mean
you need to do something he was an
American rapper author actor and poet he
sold over 75 million records worldwide
making it one of the best-selling
artists of all time he consistently
ranks as one of the greatest rappers
ever
he's Tupac and here are his top 10 rules
for success what do you think you're
most known for your acting your music or
the controversy that surrounds you my
big box yeah my big mouth I got a big
mouth came out I talked to my heart I'm
real you know saying whatever comes
comes but my controversy privately and
it's not my fault I'm trying to find my
way in the world you know I'm trying to
be somebody instead of just make money
off everybody you know I'm saying so I
go down past that haven't been travel
before and I usually mess up but I learn
you know saying I come back stronger you
know I'm not talking ignorant you know
I'm saying so I obviously put thought
into what I do so I think my mouth my
car's runs out I have not been out of
the papers since I've been since I
joined Digital Underground I've been in
all you know I'm saying is never my name
is not something not uttered you know
saying and that's good for me because I
don't want to be forgotten if I'm
forgotten then that means I'm
comfortable and I means I think
everything else okay my mother taught me
three things respect knowledge search
for knowledge it's an eternal eternal
journey that's like man you cut the line
360 degrees by knowledge always and and
she taught me to not be quiet to if
there's something my mind's speaking
that's what God that was a breath she
always taught but also the less
and Chili's he told me this little joke
that God gave you two ears to listen to
one vowel to speak to ears and one mouth
common sense one month you should speak
but your souls will listen and that's
where the knowledge comes from listening
and once you get the knowledge and you
can speak and it helps you so she taught
me respect knowledge and understanding
mostly you know just listen over one of
the characterizations made of rappers
often is that they're very boastful it
seems like right now you're taking pains
to be humble and look at things from a
very realistic perspective is that yeah
accurate mm-hmm I think being humble is
sexy it's too much money here I mean
nobody should be hitting lotto 436
million and we got people starving in
the streets that is not idealistic
that's just real that is just stupid
there's no way Michael Jackson should
have or whoever Jackson should have a
million thousand Drupal billion dollars
and there's people starving there's no
way there's no way do these people
should own planes and their people don't
have houses apartments shacks drawers
pants I know you rich I know you got
forty billion dollars but can you just
keep it to one house you only need one
house and if you only got two kids can
you just keep it to two rooms I mean
well I have 52 rooms and you notice
somebody with no room it just don't make
sense to me they don't and then these
people celebrate Christmas they got big
trees huge trees all the little
trimmings everybody got gifts and it
somebody starving and they're having a
white Christmas they having a great
Christmas eggnog and the whole nine
that's not fair to me all the society is
doing is leeching off the ghetto they
used to get them for their pain for
their sorrow for their culture for their
music for their happiness for their
movies to talk about boys you know I'm
saying I don't want to be another young
I don't want to be fifty years old at a
BDT we shall overcome achievement awards
you know I'm saying uh-uh not me
you know I mean when they see me they
know that every day when I'm breathing
it's for us to go farther you know every
time I speak I want the truth to come
out you know say every time I speak I
want to ship
you know I don't want them to be like
they know what I'm going to say because
it's polite they know what I'm going to
say and even if I get in trouble you
know I'm saying that ain't that what
we're supposed to do it's I'm not saying
I'm going to rule the world or I'm going
to change the world but I guarantee that
I will spark the brain that will change
the world and that's our job is to spark
somebody else watching us we might not
be the ones but let's not be selfish and
because we're not going to change the
world let's not talk about how we should
change it I don't know how to change it
but I know if I keep talking about how
dirty it is out here somebody gonna
clean it up I can't hold the job I just
quit my job today actually because I
wanted to come and do this and they
would let me and I felt like it was
important and it was more important than
serving pizza and we had enough people
so I felt like since I'm an actor they
should understand they should let me do
it but they didn't and I had a cold so
they were making me work in a freezer
and I really not wanted to be
disrespected I felt like that was just
respectful because I had to go you know
so I quit and he told me I couldn't quit
and that even made me hyper and I'm
arrogant so when you told me I couldn't
quit and we had all these customers I
chose that time to jump on the soapbox
grab my leather jacket light a cigarette
in front of him smoke and leave in the
middle of a rush so that was natural
that's arrogance at the time I can't
explain why
I shine and no one else I think
everybody shines and different things
and a lot of things I can't do I can't
play basketball like every other black
person in America but I can act I know
how to go to that true spot myself
because I'm there every day I can be me
I can be whoever because I'm true to me
I can go to neutral easily a lot of
people black white Mexican young or old
fat or skin you have a problem being
true to themself they have a problem
looking in the mirror and looking
directly into their own souls the reason
I sell six million records the reason I
could go to jail and come out without a
scratch the reason I can walk around the
reason I am lying today is because I can
look directly into my face and find my
soul there it's not sold I didn't sell
it it's still within me I still feel it
my heart is still connected to my body
sock I could any character imma bring
that intensity that truth and honesty to
it because I have to repay owe for that
blessing from black Jesus from God I
have to pay for that by shining if you
give you the voltage and you waste it
that's the curse he gave me the voltage
I'm a Shawn it's not mine it's from God
it's God not that it's so especially
that nobody got it but all of our gifts
and blessings and and our shrimps and
our weaknesses come from God to come
from black Jesus or whoever comes from
within you you know I mean so it's not
really tricky everybody can do it if
they just can go to that spot I guess
all the things that happen to me in my
life allow me to go there easier the
intensity of the music has built to the
no hope the I don't give a attitude how
did we get from from Grandmaster Flash
the message to where we are now in
hip-hop um again you have to be logical
you know if if I know in this hotel room
they have food every day and I'm
knocking on the door every day to eat
and they tell and they open the door let
me see the party let me see like they
throw and salami all over that but let
me just like throwing food around
we're telling me there's no food in
there you know I'm saying every day I'm
standing outside trying to sing my way
you know I'm saying we argue please let
us in we please doesn't say after about
a week that song is gonna change the we
hungry we need some food after two three
weeks it's like you know give me a
little ragged on a dawn after year you
just like you know I'm saying I'm
picking a lot coming through the door
blasting us and it's like you hungry you
reached your level you don't want
anymore we ask ten years ago we was
asking with the Panthers who was asking
with them you know a civil rights
movement it was asking you know now
those people that were asking they're
all dead and in jail so now what do you
think we're going to do and we should be
angry and my raps that I'm rapping to my
community shouldn't be filled with rage
you know I'm saying they shouldn't be
filled with the same atrocities that
they gave to me in the media they don't
talk about it so my raps I have to talk
about it and it just seems foreign
because there's no one else talking
about it right well a playing devil's
advocate somebody might say well what
does Tupac have he's a movie star he's
got you know hit records what does he
have to complain about and I'ma tell you
um it's like being the last person alive
you don't send after three days you
can't do anything what can I do
where can I go there's no there's no
black neighborhood you know saying we're
black people who have the same amount of
money as me you know saying that's
richer and that's poor there's no just
you know did a movie got a little bit
already living okay black neighborhood I
have to be in a white neighborhood
so I don't fit in that's hell it's hell
when you can't be around your peers all
my life groove around black people for
people but I can't live around poor
people now because they robbed me and
why would they write me because they're
starving because there's no money here
but they're telling me now that I made a
little money I have to move here so it's
not like no-one's ever trying to deal
with this section they're just moving
away from it we've got more stars coming
from the get over their own they're
gonna all move this way if you grew up
happy too happy
you know like in fairytale land not
fairytale I mean if you grew up where
you know every Christmas you got a
president every birthday you got a
present and every holiday was a holiday
and everything was peachy of your
parents took care everything you just
grew up I don't think that prepares you
for
the world you know my mother had a
really bad childhood and my father had a
bad childhood and I had about two other
but I loved my childhood even though it
was bad I loved it
I feel like it's taught me so much and I
feel like nothing can faze me you know
nothing in this world nothing can
surprise me it might set me back but
only momentarily only to spring back and
I think it's helped me um to learn it
really did help me learn and since my
mother had a bad childhood
she knows the importance of being honest
and the importance of facing each
situation as it comes and not dealing in
fairytale land being realistic about the
problem and analyzing it and solve it
see what you can do to solve it so if
you have a happy childhood you tend to
want your child to have a happy
childhood so you tend to want to keep
the bad things out and I don't think
that's good because you don't prepare
for the world right you have to be
realistic
telling them we don't get the wrong idea
I feel like I'm being gloomy I don't
mean just be like damn it is bad out
there but I mean when the good things
coming they are gonna come and everybody
knows that good things are going to come
and you're going to see them for
yourself you guys do you think but it's
hard to see the bad things and everybody
wants to shield the bad things that's
where it gets complicated and gets real
frightened that's when everybody gets
surprised and oh my god I'm committing
suicide that's too much overwhelming it
but does it if you know about it won't
be so overwhelming no sounds nothing
about that all be SSI it all comes down
to we got to survive I mean even
warriors put their spirits down on
Sundays we got to survive here in this
country because I'm not going back to
Africa we got to survive here for us to
survive here white folks black folks
Korean folks Mexican folks Puerto Ricans
we got to understand each other we got
to take take a bigger chance and when I
say Americans people think I'm talking
about Uncle Sam I mean like actually
Uncle Sam with the gray hair and the
flag I mean you you you the guy you know
you the mechanic wherever you I mean you
need to do something thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know which
of Tupac's top ten rules
the most to you at the biggest impact
leave it at comments below and I'll join
in the discussion and tell us which one
for you on us feature on this channel
next time thank you guys for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon